I actually would tell you I fascinate
sometimes over losing everything and
then having love you guys write articles
like see he wasn't that good he was a
full of [ __ ] and then rising like a
phoenix and being like [ __ ] you yes
that'd be great thank you
nice view huh
good morning you know it's funny I was
in Mexico City there was some sort of
speaker just really intelligent I didn't
understand a word he was saying but one
of the things he said was 85% of what we
do is irrational and it was a really
interesting moment for me because when
we talk about disruption and change and
things of that nature you understand my
dad was made fun of constantly in 1996
and 7 by all his liquor store friends
for not opening a second liquor store
and letting his son launch a website
there are people in this room looking at
the age group that remember very strong
conversations in 1994 through 1998 that
the internet itself was a fad not that
snapchat is a fad not that vine or
Twitter is a fad that the whole [ __ ]
platform was a fad we were living
through this is this is for actually
bear with me for five minutes because
I'm going to be talking to myself you're
just going to hear it we are living
through a far bigger culture shift than
anybody in this room including myself
realizes how do you balance your own
signal to noise has this room supposed
to figure out what to pay attention to
what's visible I'm not sure but I know
it's going to be the variable of your
success right like I don't know like hey
make your asking like how do we make
good strategic decisions that become the
framework of where we dictate our
behavior I don't know what I will tell
you is it's a lot more listening than it
is talking and I talk a lot I think you
get a sense of my energy like I'm always
talking i've detox filming me right now
I produce content every single day I'm
always talking but I'm sneakily mainly
paying attention and so I produce
content for reaction so I can
contextualize that reaction and
understand the vibe of the ecosystem
there are way too many people building
companies I'm talking to startups now I
have a lot of passion for this space
you're building it in a silo you're
building it for how you see the world
playing out without spending a lot of
time with customers so I think the way
that you eliminate noise is
go to the source of what you want
good to see just need to talk earlier
about that client wanted to reach 20 to
29 years yeah with TV yeah yes you
convinced enough you know I don't
convince anybody I tell them the only
thing you can do in this environment is
Instagram and snapchat and a little bit
Facebook actually has a lot more
attention of 20 to 30 then the world
realizes it's very taken orally the
thing I didn't cook I don't convince
them my clients as big as we are as much
cloud as I have as like why would they
hire Boehner are still probably
executing in the ballpark of 4 to 6
percent of our stuff really think about
that so but I don't spend any energy on
convincing people that aren't convinced
about you know what I mean none it's
just not a good game i'll i'll but i but
you know it's fun i walk in with the
same energy i walk here i [ __ ] drill
in like roman you have to [ __ ] do
this the only right thing and then I
guess I'm empathetic to that I'm in
client services like there's plenty of
places where I get to make the final
decision in that environment I don't
and what's really worked for me and I
think here's the real punchline to give
you real I'm gonna win like the reason
we're at four to six percent from 0%
last year is they were saw that I was
right
I know by the way who are you we weren't
a real pleasure thank you area I'm
pretty much about my life double my gear
I need to get a double mic t-shirts tea
Rock I just think it's you've got to
rethink the entire thing but to break
through the noise you on on by
definition you have to do something
fundamentally different than what
everybody else is doing and everybody
else is doing the same thing I call it
the Taylor Swift rule so I think so I
think Taylor Swift hacked culture I
think Kanye does it as well believe it
or not here's what they do you scale the
unscalable if you want to break through
the noise today so let me explain what
Taylor Swift's very good at is she knows
that when people tweet her and say
Taylor come to my wedding and sing me a
song she actually doesn't here's why she
does it the 75-minute
allocation of her time to do something
like that is not ROI positive for Taylor
based on what she makes for her time
however the amplification of doing
something that makes no sense on paper
is where she gets all her value so I get
yelled out by all my smartest CEO
friends the most fancy gals and guys on
earth for still answering all these
tweets and emails and replying one by
one on snapchat but I know that depth is
far more interesting than with in a
world where the width has just become
completely obnoxiously loud and
impossible to break through truth is
there are characters that look like me
running around there are people that
understand I know not that many but but
but you can get somebody into an honest
conversation because they do not have
aligned interests they don't and the
only they start the relationship with
knowing each other not at all and that's
the closest on a line interest they'll
ever be and this is all that happens and
it breaks so to me let's just [ __ ]
get it out of the way I just think
communications very valuable like it
just works it just nobody does it like
really I mean a great communicators win
in life especially you know back to why
I married my wife five seconds into our
first date especially you're lucky
enough to find another great
communicator and that's where
relationships and that's where business
partnerships car I just think it's
better to know that it's not going to
work upfront you know for me all my
diamonds come from the friction of how I
see things versus how I'm hearing
everybody else talk about them and so
that's where my practicality comes from
because the e-wrap what I consider to be
irrational back to that is helping me
understand listen just because I believe
this if the consumer or the target is
not going to go there it's not going to
matter how I see it I mean I have no
interest in being historically right in
a 150 year window I'll be [ __ ] dead
all right take care guys all right ready
thank you yeah take care of yourself
thank you thank you all right we're
stuck in an elevator here that's fun
I listen if I could write and this is a
DNA thing but anything I can do to
subtract emotion and romance out of your
body I would you know
the passion and delusion are two very
different things